a lot of it was just you know ability to
to get a grip on the ball and be able to
throw the ball accurately and just you
know be myself and not think about it
and be able to play confidently and so
as soon as I could grip it and rip it
then you know I don't wanted to play
only to be out there with my teammates
drew brees ripping it and gripping it
and getting it done for the New Orleans
Saints on Sunday he's back he looks
great there was a lot of question big
cat in the under-pressure Draft on
Friday you know when you were sound
asleep and dad and I are actually
working
he put drew brees in that spot because
he kind of forced his way back onto the
field kind of had that vibe to it yeah
and and he's putting himself in a big
spot there and it worked it paid off and
he looked really good its superlatives
time obviously drew Brees is one of them
were already talked about what he did on
Sunday Chris give me one of your super
that is coming out of week 8 well we
haven't hit on this game yet but I mean
you know I'm gonna give these
self-inflicted wounds to the Cleveland
Browns ok I mean just self inflicted on
themselves inflicted on self inflicted
yes I mean what the hell okay I mean
they went through a stretch the other
day or yesterday it was where it was at
three consecutive plays in a row turning
the football over you know the Cleveland
Browns you know again yesterday that
game was there to be had to be very
close and make it interesting I mean you
they were not gonna out classified like
the New England Patriots in the sense of
oh my gosh they don't even belong on the
same field here you know this is the
second week in a row we're seeing the
Cleveland Browns where you know before
their bye week outplayed the Seattle
Seahawks and made it a lot of stupid
turnovers there yesterday you know just
with not only to start the game the
fumble by Nick Chubb where his own guy
kind of kicked the ball out of his hands
that gets returned for a touchdown ok
damn you're you're in the hole against
the New England Patriots were you wanted
to be when you go up to New England and
then you know the next time he touches
the ball makes a phenomenal run you know
breaking through the line of scrimmage
make some people miss and you go oh my
god she's off to the races look
Cleveland they're looking good and
Jonathan Jones comes behind and strips
the ball I mean those are those are
chances just like we talked about the
Bears a little bit ago you know when you
have a chance there to make it a game or
put the team in a pressure position as
far as into
I'm Patriots and you don't me really
capitalized on it that's when you lose
by two touchdowns and you're down 27 to
13 late in the fourth quarter and just a
lot of mistakes there overall by
Cleveland yeah and you know it did feel
like they had more of an opportunity
than we would have given them credit for
they still lost by 14 it didn't feel
like you know at times it felt like they
were gonna lose by 40 but they just kind
of hung around they do then the Patriots
didn't deliver that death blow and I got
to give the Browns some credit for sure
the bottom line though is there's still
two and five through seven games this is
not what anyone thought it was going to
be for the Cleveland Browns this season
the schedule does soften a little bit
but but they're down to maybe two more
losses that they can talk about they go
seven and two down the stretch basically
and and to even have a chance of getting
in and that's going to be difficult for
them to do all right
my first award is the clear and obvious
visual evidence award because finally
finally we see the defensive pass
interference replay review actually used
after all these weeks of coaches wasting
their read challenge flag Frank Reich of
the cults yeah after T Y Hilton's left
arm right he's running a crossing route
where you typically like to you know put
two hands out to make the catch by his
left arm is being pulled behind him
yanked total know and first of all how
in the hell do you not throw a flag for
defensive pass interference in real time
when you see the guy grabbing the
receivers arm from behind and holding it
but they didn't yeah so Frank Reich
throws the red flag and you know it took
a little while because I think out River
on the senior VP of officiating had to
go through this oh my gosh we have not
used this for the last five weeks and
there have been some clear and obvious
instances of significant hindrance of a
receiver but I've been told to push the
bar really high and I don't want to get
in trouble for actually doing this but
how can I not call this defensive pass
interference when the guy's hand was
being held behind his back rhaggy know
the old phrase hey I could do that with
one hand a hand tied behind my back huh
no you can't you can't you can't
that's significant hindrance having a
hand held behind your back so on one
hand I want to give out River on credit
yeah for overturning the non call of
pass interference but on the other hand
it just demonstrates
how many other times he should have and
look I'd rather it not be overused but
but where is the line here yeah I think
yesterday further confirms nobody really
knows where the line is yeah no I mean I
get you I'm glad they got this right I
mean this is like if you watch TV he's
holding his hand behind his back that is
I mean I think that's why this is where
the rule was really intended I think
this is what the NFL wants like things
are they're so egregious this was a huge
point in the football game it was a
third down and I think that's where
we'll see when it's that obvious now
we've seen those in he hasn't car I get
you I don't know if we've seen any that
bad there we buy right Philadelphia
Eagles out Sean yeah before that mark
was Valdo scantling blown up by a
Fontaine Maddox yeah ball comes in yeah
no pass interference no I think that
would be the one where I'd go that
probably should have been called then
there was for even one in the Lions
Packers game where I think it was Kenny
holiday way down the field those jump
out to me where I go oh that was
egregious that should be overturned I
understand like the NFL if it's a little
hand fighting on both sides and you know
it was they're gonna stay with what was
you know called on the field what do you
do if you're a coach now when do you
throw the red flag we've been telling
him for weeks you're stupid for throwing
the red flag Frank Reich frozen it pays
off now you got to revisit that well
yeah that that's one no I think that you
do you just you gotta have the right
people in your ear to go Oh Frank you
know this is more than just two guys
like fighting for position this is truly
like plain as day like you said the
Yanks is armed back and I you know you
it's it's not back performs a de-facto
arm amputation of the receiver then
something that raises right yeah I think
that's basically where we're going it's
the bottom line yeah you got to catch
that in Realty you shouldn't ever ever
run never should be in that position
well gotta he's got a rule defensive
pass interference from afar how do the
officials not see that I that's what
drives me crazy that's the point to me
when when like they go like oh I saw
illegal hands to the face I'm 95 yards
away as pinky finger touched it but then
they don't see that down the middle of
the field you're like what I mean I see
stupid calls all over the league where
you go why even calling that like oh the
guy's hands touched his face
50 yards away from the play like what
didn't matter but we're gonna call that
but here this isn't the biggest moment
where it's like the go to wide receiver
for the team and somehow that does not
get seen I don't get that prime example
of how sky judge could be used to the
NFL's benefit that would be a spot where
a video official could say to the
referee drop a flag there was past
interference on that play no replay
review a member of the crew who's in a
booth who says everybody saw that T Y
Hilton had his arm pulled behind his
back you got a call pass interference
and you move on quickly all right let's
move on what's your next wholly run game
okay wholly run game and that goes to
the San Francisco 49ers Kyle Shanahan
mad scientist I mean it was just
unbelievable yesterday the Carolina
Panthers defense is one of the better
units in all of football and I don't
know for anybody who didn't watch that
game yesterday I mean the 49ers just
basically we just watched them go up and
down the field and then their defense
started to create turnovers but and what
I want to say with the wholly run game
and you know Kyle Shanahan the mad
scientist in the run game you know just
some of the plays they had within the
game were unbelievable it wasn't like it
was like oh hey we're just running off
left tackle you've seen us do this run
play before here we go we just happen to
block it writing us the right David snow
so many of the big plays we saw
yesterday was was through the design and
trickeration of a Kyle Shanahan to keep
defenses off-balance and just great play
design where you go wow I've never even
seen some of this stuff before
I mean Tevin Coleman was yeah four
touchdowns rushing or was it four
touchdowns total am i right yeah three
rushing one kept receiving but I mean
some of these plays as you see I mean
this is Luke Kuechly in the Carolina
Panthers and these guys aren't down in
two in touch with two weeks to get ready
for the game that's what I mean them is
to n touch games and these guys are
running free for a touchdown so I just
so impressive and it just the 49ers
they're real I mean they're really real
and just another week where we go by and
they go Patriots 49ers Superbowl down
into Miami it's gonna be amazing
it's the I mean it's just I just look at
it and go wow they're just phenomenal
right now there have been 11 to 23 the
49ers have outscored their opponents
- by week they keep getting better the
schedule gets a little more difficult
we'll see what they can do I thought you
were gonna take mine
my superlative is the John D Filippo
memorial run the football award because
the Philadelphia Eagles cut the team
where D Filippo was but that became the
Vikings offensive coordinator and was
fired last year right we're not running
the ball enough
the Eagles woke up and ran the football
on Sunday against the bills it helped
that it was windy but still they got it
done and they ran four more yards
against the bills in the second half
than anyone had run against the bills
for an entire game surprising 31 to 39
of the games we disagreed on last
Thursday yeah I just felt there's
something about the Eagles when they are
backed against the wall they find a way
and it's sad that it takes that yeah for
them to find a way right they're good
enough to win when they're not backed
against the wall but that's how it was
all shaping up and the bills I wasn't
impressed with what they did against the
Dolphins a prior week they won by 10 it
was much closer than that well it could
have been should have lost that game I
just felt like it was time it was time
for a little correction for the bills
and a big correction for the Eagles by
running the football and hopefully for
them this is the thing that springboards
them to win after win after all and
they're gonna look if you don't win the
division in the NFC East you you're
probably not getting into the playoffs
right now yeah they're gonna have to
string some wins together and their
schedule does get more difficult they
got the Bears then they have their bye
week they've got the Patriots and
Seahawks after that three straight home
games to go with the three straight road
games they just suffered through but
they finally got a win and now they can
try to turn it well if they play like
they did yesterday which they got
healthy in the secondary you sell the
defensive line show sometimes of
dominance in the football game if they
can get to Sean Jackson back I don't
care who's on their schedule and they
will just run the ball the way they did
yesterday and I don't mean just like run
it for the stats to it it's the way they
ran it the Philadelphia Eagles are one
of those like whoo when they get off the
buses they're one of the like best
ass-kicking looking teams in football
okay and they got big guys up front and
what what I saw yesterday and if you're
just watching it on TV with the mile
Sanders run sophomore downhill runs
yesterday by the Philadelphia Eagles and
I've seen probably in the first six
weeks combined or seven weeks combined
from the Eagles the eagle
are at their best in their 2017 Super
Bowl run when they were steamrolling
teams with guys like Kelsey and Brandon
Brooks upfront and of course Lane
Johnson and you know whoever it is at
left tackle right now it's still big
Road greater type they need to get back
to that they became like the kings of
like the five and eight yard pass of the
world and it's just not the risk/reward
not the same the Eagles yesterday
Carson Wentz was underneath the center
they ran the ball down hill and they
were a lot more fun to watch and they're
they're a better team because of it and
one thing to keep in mind a huge
difference between three and five and
four and four they may be buyers at the
trade deadline I was told yesterday
after the game they're considering and I
know this sounds trite but it's kind of
neat behead something fun you know what
can we do what you're in a position
where you'd already mentally decided to
give up a first-round pick in the second
round pick for Jalen Ramsey and that
trade didn't happen yeah once you it's
all it's like once you've decided to
spend that capital once you've crossed
that bridge you're kind of willing
you're you've already decided you're
gonna use that and I'm not saying
they're gonna give up a one in a two for
somebody but I feel like they they
recognize there's an opportunity to be
had there to make a move at the trade
deadline whether it's for a receiver who
can do what DeSean Jackson hasn't been
doing for that or a defensive player
defensive back pass rusher but it could
be in one of those three they're gonna
try whether or not they do it whether or
not they pull it off for me to be seen
but I think they're gonna try to do
something that we're gonna look at and
say wow the Eagles are making their move
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports